oh try to make a mold yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's beautiful and show it to my
mom
um you guys ever pull a worm out your
butt before oh wow
what happened caught that wasn't part of
the line baby but i respect what you're
talking about
and i respect all women and i think that
well you guys didn't have worms when you
were younger
no yeah people did have them i didn't
get them
i got lice i got warming oh i had like
two wait wait so
in the philippines you just rando get
random no no no no i was a real dirty
kid
my my dad didn't let us wear like even a
t-shirt until we were like 11. we were
just in our underwear
oh yeah we're just like wild little
mowgli's yes and so i never wore
slippers and that's how you get worms
and i
would yeah i got worms and i'd pull them
out i felt so good i remember feeling
like wow
how big are we talking uh one of them
was real long i felt something slimy and
then i pulled it out and i swear like my
eyes rolled in the back of my head it
felt so good
i had a worm on my butt you did yeah my
friend alan tried to [ __ ] me
allen yeah camp yeah a jewish guy or not
i don't know you wasn't jewish whoa dude
no alan is a
you know i got i've got three friends
named allen all of them are jewish
i know his name i just didn't know i
can't i don't see his last name if you
just said randall i wouldn't have said
oh
i told you i had gay experiences when i
was a kid yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah everybody so i did you try to
do a call back from like
50 episodes ago well i'm sure i try to
do a callback a lot of people
it didn't land the way i wanted to land
i'll be honest i got it though
i was thinking about alan the ellen joke
yeah right the worm of my [ __ ] alan
joe yeah
for about 30 seconds and in my head i
was like should i throw it out
i threw it out you did obviously it's
documented
yeah i threw it out it's here and then
it it had an
uncomfortable land right
yeah you mean really no humor yeah then
you guys started questioning me
yeah yeah was how old was alan that was
whatever right
alan i know my point is is that wait
wait l i [ __ ] the joke wait this is
gonna answer your question
is it alan with it a-l-a-n or an
a-l-l-e-n
because that might answer answer your
question i don't know
what is it there's no alan there is no
there is no father
no alan yeah oh god oh my god
the before
throw a little frickin i'd slip a little
dang sunflower seed up there for it um
inside of my butt you'd feed the worm to
bait it or i mean if i was young and i
you know
cared about animals and stuff yeah i bet
i would you know get you a little
you know a little cinnamon stick or
something just you know give it a little
one of those good and plenty you ever
had one of them
what's a good one it's a candy small
shaped candy
you probably wouldn't even feel it in
your in your butt you know yeah
but oh but it oh
a good and plenty i've never heard of it
the candy so um let me just ask you some
questions about this one
purple one all right i can't see i've
never had oh so it's not chocolate based
no i wouldn't do that okay so good
chocolate
do you think i'm a damn school shooter
oh man yeah okay so it's chocolatey safe
yeah it is booty it's it's fruity it's
fruity oh it's like a licorice it's kind
of licorice it's a licoricey
and the shape is from what i saw from
the thing the shape's tube shaped it's
conducive yet to a butt
oh it looks like a thinner pill yes yes
i know what a good in plenty is yeah
i've done it before
yeah so if i had a yeah but pulling a
worm out of your butt seems just damn
god yeah hmm so what would you make this
should be like a national sport or
something in some of those
kind of foreign countries you know and
one of our national sports is spider
fighting you guys do that in louisiana
where you put two spiders on a stick and
you fight it out
and then the other spider eventually
like kills the other spider and then you
bet money